The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So the
goal for today is
to talk about a particular kind
of communication network called
a shared medium network.
And there are
many, many examples
of shared media communication
networks that exist today.
Now, these are,
generally speaking,
networks that don't span the
globe or even span the country,
with one exception,
and that exception
is the satellite
network shown here.
The model here is that you
have a set of ground stations.
This is a picture from an
actual internet service provider
in the middle of the Pacific.
I mean, I'd love to go
there on assignment.
And the way this network
works is in order
to communicate
between these islands,
the way they do this is
they have satellite ground
stations that can receive
and transmit data.
And there's a satellite
up in the sky.
So you communicate between
two of these islands
by transmitting data from
one of the ground stations
up to the satellite
and down there.
And the way this system works
is not to divide frequencies
amongst the
different satellites.
And the reason
they don't do that
is that they don't
know how often each
of these satellites--
these ground stations
is going to communicate.
So you don't divide up
the frequencies upfront
between the ground stations.
So all of the ground stations
sending to the satellite
do so on the same frequency.
And the satellite downlink
is on a different frequency.
So what could happen if two
satellites communicate up
at the same time is
that the satellite up--
if two ground
stations communicate
to the satellite
at the same time,
the satellite may not be
able to pull together the two
different transmissions
apart because they're
on the same frequency.
Now, they could use frequency
division multiplexing.
That's a perfectly
reasonable solution.
But they don't do it because
if one satellite-- one ground
station has data to send
and the other doesn't, you
end up wasting
frequencies and not
getting as high a throughput.
So that's one example of
a shared medium network.
This here is a picture of
something called ethernet,
which was one of the most
successful networking
technologies developed.
It was invented in
the early 1970s.
And the idea here is you have
a shared bus, a shared wire,
and many stations connect to it.
And if two stations
transmit at the same time,
the two transmissions
could collide
and you don't actually
receive the data.
And what you would like
to do is to figure out
a way by which these
different stations
or nodes on the
ethernet can somehow
manage to communicate by
collaboratively figuring out
how to transmit on the medium.
And the idea is to make it so
that only one node transmits
at any point in time.
Other examples of shared
media are wireless networks.
802.11 is an example of a
shared communication medium.
If a bunch of us communicate
and share that access point,
we're all running
on the same channel.
And in 802.11, or
Wi-Fi, there are
a bunch of different
channels available.
But any given axis
point tends to have
a cell, which is
some area around it
that, in order to communicate
with that access point,
you use the same channel.
So we need a way by which we
have to take the shared network
and allocate access
to this medium
amongst these different nodes.
And if you look at
an entire building,
there's a big plan in place
for how the different access
points communicate potentially
on different channels
or the same channel.
And there's an entire process
by which this building's network
is laid out and the
campus network is laid out
and so forth.
And cellular
networks-- you know,
Verizon, AT&T, Sprint and
T-Mobile and all these guys
have the same problem
that they have to solve.
So these are very
interesting questions
which boil down to how
you take a shared medium--
whether it be a wire like an
ethernet net or radio, which
is over the air, or
it could be acoustic--
how do you take all of that and
have these different nodes that
are communicating
with each other on
that medium somehow make
it so that they can all
share the medium without
colliding with each other?
And that's the problem
that's solved by these media
access or MAC protocols.
Now, all of the stuff
that I'm going to tell you
is based on chapter 15,
which is on MAC protocols.
And there's a little
more in it than we'll
be able to cover in recitation,
in lecture and recitation.
But it's hard for me to keep
straight what we cover and what
we don't.
So you're sort of responsible
for everything in that chapter.
We'll cover most of the issues.
There's a bunch of details
in the chapter that
are worth understanding
in order for you
to really get your
understanding to be clear.
So I want to caveat
that upfront.
We lost a lecture
because of the hurricane.
And I just can't keep straight
what I tell you and what I
don't.
So everything in that
chapter is fair game.
But we'll cover the
most important issues.
OK.
So here's the abstract model.
And you know, there's
a shared medium.
It could be a wire.
It could be wireless.
And you have these nodes.
And the nodes have
two things there
that you have to worry about.
The first thing here
is just a detail.
It's the channel interface.
It's a way by which
the data on that node
gains access to the medium.
And then each node
has a set of queues--
or one queue or two queues,
a transmit queue and a
receive queue, which
has packets waiting
to be sent on that medium.
And the basic idea
is that you have
all these nodes on the medium.
And it may be that
these nodes are all
trying to communicate with
a single router or a switch
or a satellite.
Or it may be that the
nodes are directly
communicating with each
other, like your laptop is
communicating with mine.
Your phone is communicating
with your laptop.
And somehow they're all
sharing this medium.
And we're going to come up
with the world's simplest
shared medium network
because it's simple
and because it's a reasonable
model of reality, which
is that at any point in time if
more than one transmission is
on that shared medium,
then you end up
having what's
called a collision.
And you cannot
decode the packet.
So let me repeat.
The model here is
if there's exactly
one transmission on
the medium, we'll
assume that it's
delivered correctly.
If there is no transmission
on the medium at some point
in time, nothing happens.
The channel is sort of wasted.
It's not used.
If there's more than one
transmission on the medium
overlapping in time,
neither transmission
successfully gets decoded.
So there are two
or three or four
people hitting the
channel at the same time
overlapping in time.
Nobody succeeds.
OK.
That's the abstraction.
And what we want is a
communication protocol or rules
of engagement between
the nodes that
allow us to get reasonably
good performance in sharing
the medium.
Now, depending on the
details of the network,
the nodes that are
on this shared medium
may be able to hear
each other perfectly.
Or maybe they can't
hear each other at all.
Or maybe they can
partially hear each other.
And we're going to deal
with all of these cases.
But for now, just
assume that you
have these nodes on the medium.
And for simplicity
and completeness,
let's take the example
of the satellite network.
You have a satellite up here.
And you have a bunch
of ground stations
that are all trying to
communicate up to the satellite
whenever they have data to send.
And just assume for now that the
nodes cannot hear each other.
And the satellite
doesn't really know
whether a node has packets
waiting to be sent or not.
And somehow, we're
going to invent
a protocol or a rules
of engagement that
allow these nodes to,
in a distributed way,
figure out when it's OK
for them to transmit data
and when they should
keep their mouth shut.
And each of these
nodes has a queue
of packets waiting to be sent.
Sometimes the
queue may be empty.
Sometimes the queue may
have one or more packets.
That depends on what
the application is doing
and how quickly that node has
been able to transmit data
on the channel.
If the node has packets
waiting to be sent,
so a queue can either be empty
or it has one or more packets
waiting to be sent.
In which case, we're going
to use the word backlogged.
So at any point in time,
some subset of the nodes
may have backlogged packets and
that may have backlog queues.
And our goal is to come up with
a way by which these nodes can
transmit data on the channel.
Now, there are two or
three different ways
of solving this problem.
The first approach to
solving this problem
is to do frequency
division multiplexing.
You could just allocate
different frequencies
and you've solved the problem.
But as I mentioned
before, we don't
want to do that because if
you've allocated and predefined
a frequency to a node
and the node is empty,
it doesn't have packets,
then you've essentially
wasted bandwidth
because you've allocated
a portion of the frequency
to a node that isn't actually
going to send any data.
Somebody else who
had data to send
could have more profitably
used it and helped you win,
helped you get
better performance.
The second thing you can do
is to somehow divide up time.
In other words, they all
run on the same frequency.
And somehow make it so
that you give the illusion
that each node gets
access to the channel
for some fraction of the time.
And if you do that,
it's a model of sharing
called time sharing as
opposed to frequency sharing.
So one approach to dealing with
it is frequency sharing, which
is a good idea in
some cases, but not
in this case when the
traffic is quite bursting.
The second thing you
can do is time sharing.
And there are two ways
of doing time sharing.
One of them is called time
division multiplexing, or TDM.
It's also called TDMA for
Time Division Multiple Access.
And we'll talk about this
in recitation tomorrow,
so I won't belabor it here.
The second approach to
solving this problem,
which is what we'll spend
the rest of today on,
is the class of protocols
called contention protocols.
And these protocols
are really beautiful,
because they're
completely distributed.
There's no central intelligence.
It's highly distributed
intelligence.
Each node makes its own
independent decisions
as to what it should do based
on very little information
that it learns as it sends
its packets and determines
what happens to those packets.
And yet, somehow the
nodes are able to come up
with a way of sharing the
channel by essentially
cooperating but yet
competing with each other.
That's why these are called
contention protocols.
That ends up getting
pretty good performance.
There's a third kind
of sharing, which
we won't talk about at all in
602, and that's code division.
The slides that are online
say a little bit about it.
And you can look it up on
the internet, if you want.
We're not going to
talk about it here.
So for today, my goal is to tell
you about contention protocols.
And largely speaking, for
MAC protocols right now
in this chapter and
this part of the course,
we're interested in time
sharing, TDMA and contention.
So before I tell you
about the protocols,
I want to tell you a
little bit about what
we would like, what
makes the protocol good
and what doesn't, what's bad.
So if I tell you that you have
a bunch of these nodes that
are trying to share
this medium and you
would like to get good
performance in this protocol
to share access to the channel,
by what metric or metrics
would you measure
this performance?
How would you know
it's good or bad?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well, the model
here is if two people send
at the same time, you fail.
We fail.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: OK.
So good, let's keep
going with that.
Now let's say that someone
observes the system
and watches its
evolution over time.
They observe whether packets
succeed and packets fail
and so forth.
And they want to
count something.
What would they
count to determine
if a protocol is good or bad?
AUDIENCE: Rate of failure?
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
PROFESSOR: Rate of failure.
I mean, live your
positive, people,
so let's count the
rate of success.
OK, so there's a word
for this rate of success.
It's a measure
of, if you succeed
more, it means you're able
to deliver data faster,
which means you get higher
throughput or a higher rate.
So the first metric that you
have-- so these are metrics.
The first metric that
you have is throughput.
And throughput is generally
measured in bits per second
or packets per second.
So let's just imagine
that it's packets
per second for simplicity to
assume that all the packets are
the same size.
So you can translate
into bits per second.
Now, throughput by
itself is a good metric.
But really, we would
like protocols--
we would like to
evaluate protocols
without worrying about whether
the underlying channel can send
data at 1 megabit per second
or 10 megabits per second
or a gigabit per second or
100 gigabits per second.
I mean, we really
don't want to care
about what the actual
throughput or the rate
supportable by the channel is.
So we're going to
translate this throughput
into a different
word which means--
which is a proxy for throughput
called the utilization.
And we'll represent that by U.
And the utilization
of a MAC protocol--
or in fact, of any
protocol over a network--
is defined as the throughput
that the protocol achieves
divided by the maximum
rate at which it's
possible to send data over that
channel or over that network.
So if you have a sudden maximum
rate at which if everything
were in your favor
you could send data
at a certain maximum rate,
stick that in the denominator.
Look at what throughput
you actually get.
And take the ratio.
The higher the utilization,
the higher the throughput.
We've just normalized
out by the maximum rate.
And of course, by
definition, we know
that the utilization
must be between 0 and 1
because you can't
exceed the maximum.
And this is an
aggregate measure.
So if you have, let's say,
four nodes and the max--
just for example,
let's say the max
rate is 10 megabits per second
and you have four nodes.
And the throughput that the
four nodes get are, let's say,
1 megabits per second,
2 megabits per second,
4 megabits per second,
and 1 megabit per second.
What's the utilization?
The total throughput is
8 megabits per second.
The maximum is 10.
So the utilization in
this example is 0.8.
In fact, if you had--
for the same four nodes,
if the throughput you got
was 0, 1, 7, and 1, the
utilization would also be 0.8.
Can't add.
Can't multiply.
But can convolve.
All right.
Now, which of these
two is better?
That depends on if you're
a Democrat or a Republican.
But which of those
two is better?
If you were designing a network,
which of these would you want?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: What?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, a Democrat.
This is a tough question.
You might say that
everybody should--
they should be as
equal as possible.
You might say that they
should get proportion
to what they pay for.
There's various ways
of thinking about this.
We're not going to
worry about the--
I mean, it's actually
a pretty deep set
of topics that connect with
economics and social justice
and so on.
And a lot of people do work on
what it means to have fairness
and what it means--
different kinds of fairness.
And for those who
are interested,
I can point you to
lots of literature.
And it's still somewhat open in
terms of, what is the right way
to think about it?
We're simple people.
We'll just assume that
absent any other information,
we would like to get
as equal as possible.
And to do that, there are
many ways to define fairness.
And there's a particular
one that I like because it's
simple and somewhat intuitive.
And it's used a
lot in networking.
It's called the Fairness Index.
This isn't the only way
to measure fairness.
But this is one that we'll use.
And the definition
of it is that I
will look at either the
utilization or the throughput.
It doesn't matter.
Let me call that XI.
In other words, XI is the
throughput or the utilization--
let me call it throughput--
achieved by node I.
And if I look at
this number here,
XI squared divided by n
summation XI squared, that's
my definition of fairness.
Now, this looks a
little daunting.
But it's actually very simple.
What it's saying is that I
take each of the throughputs
that I get and I add them
all up and I square them.
So if I were to divide
both sides by n squared--
essentially, this is capturing
for me something that's
related to the ratio of
the square of the mean
to the variance.
So in other words, what ends
up happening with a term like
this-- this is a second
moment kind of a definition
of fairness--
this thing here looks like
the square of the mean.
This thing here is
related to the variance.
And this is capturing the
ratio of those two terms.
If you have a situation
where you have n nodes
and you end up with
everybody getting equal,
then the fairness index
is 1, because if everybody
has an equal value and you just
run the calculation through,
you'll find that the
answer is equal to 1.
So if this is F, F
is between 0 and 1.
What's the minimum
value of the Fairness
Index from this formula?
Well, that happens
when you have n guys
and the throughput looks
something like this.
One of them gets
all the throughput
and the others get 0.
And if you plug that in
here, what you'll find
is that only one
term survives, the 1
over n term, and
everything else becomes 0.
And so the minimum value of
the fairness is 1 over F.
And this is intuitive
in that it says
that if you have two people
and one guy hogs everything,
that's a little bit less
unfair than if you have
five people and one guy hogs
everything, because in a sense,
one guy hogging everything out
of five is worse than one guy
hogging everything out of two.
The only real reason we
care about this fairness
is we're going to compare
different variants
of a protocol along this index.
And I'd like you to get a feel
for what is a little fairer
and what's less fair.
There's nothing
particularly sacred
about this particular
definition of fairness.
And indeed, people
will argue also
that this is a terrible
definition of fairness
because it doesn't reflect
how much people have
paid for the resource.
But those are
details because you
could have weighted
versions where
people are weighted by how
much they pay, and so forth.
So you can handle
some of that stuff.
Is this kind of clear,
these two basic definitions?
So we're going to worry
about throughput and fairness
in protocols.
Any questions so far?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Depends on whether
you care about it or not.
I mean, it depends
on the application.
So typically speaking,
when I look at,
for example, measuring
the performance of my--
let's say I'm
downloading web pages.
When I measure the
performance of web downloads,
all header information
is just pure overhead.
So I only look at how long it's
taken to download my content.
But now I can go in and look
at how well is my TCP, which
is the transport protocol,
or IP, or whatever,
some lower level protocol
working, in which case,
everything else is overhead.
But I will include the
particular headers related
to TCP in my measurement.
So the answer to whether
something is overhead
or not is it sort of depends
on what it is you care about.
So if I'm delivering
video, you know, all
this other stuff is overhead.
And the only thing I care
about is my video frame.
So typically, the
word throughput
is by itself not meaningful.
You have to say
throughput of what.
And here I'm talking about
throughput of a protocol, which
is what you always have to say.
And this is the throughput
of the MAC protocol.
And it does include
the MAC header overhead
if you have any headers.
Any other question?
OK.
There's a third metric
that's important,
which is that we would like
to have reasonable delays.
So in general, delay
is a good metric,
or bounded delay
is a good metric.
And this matters because I can
get extremely high utilization
and extremely high
fairness by doing something
utterly dumb and naive,
which is that if I have all
these nodes with
a lot of packets,
if they're all backlogged,
then what I will say is,
today this node gets
access to the network.
Tomorrow, he gets
Day after tomorrow, he
gets access to the network.
If they're always backlogged,
then clearly the throughput
is-- the utilization is very
high, because the network is
always being used
profitably and there
are no collisions and no
idle slots, no idle time.
The network is fair,
because if I measure
this over a month or
a year or something,
everybody gets equal throughput.
But I've clobbered the delay
because this guy got lucky.
But everybody else is
waiting and waiting.
And in fact, even
he has to wait.
Once today is over, he's
got to wait many days
before he gets a turn.
So you actually would
like to have bounded
delay, or at least low delay.
And this is something
we're going to measure.
We're not going to try to
optimize in the work we're
going to talk about.
OK.
So that's the statement
of the problem
and the statement of the metrics
that we wish to optimize.
You have to ask me questions
because if the problem
setup wasn't clear, the
solution is kind of going
to be completely meaningless.
So does anyone have any
questions about the problem
statement?
It's one of these things
where stating the problem
is actually a little harder
than the actual solution.
So I'm going to tell you now one
method to solve this problem.
I'll get to you.
And the method we're going
to use to solve this problem
was invented in the context
of satellite networks
and then it got
put into ethernet
and then it's now part of Wi-Fi.
So everybody uses a
variant of the method
that we are going to study.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
how do you measure delay?
PROFESSOR: The delay
is measured per packet.
It's measured between when the
packets showed up at the queue
to when it actually successfully
got received at the receiver.
And then typically
we'll take an average
across all of the
packets and report
an average delay, and perhaps
the standard deviation.
You had a comment?
All right.
So the solution we're
going to study--
the basic solution is
something called ALOHA.
ALOHA was the protocol
developed by a group led
by Norm Abramson, who was
a professor at the time he
did this at the
University of Hawaii.
I believe he moved
from Stanford to Hawaii
because he was an avid surfer.
And he decided that-- this
was in the late '60s--
that he wanted a
scheme to connect
the different islands together.
There were seven
of these islands--
seven of these stations that
he wanted to connect together.
And he came up with a scheme
that on the face of it
should really not work.
And only think good about it
is how utterly simple it is.
And the fact that
it works is actually
very fortunate and very useful.
And the reason it works
is because, in a way,
nodes doing things that
look completely random--
as long as the
probability with which
they do these things
is controlled,
it turns out they
work pretty well.
So let me first show
you a picture that
will define a few terms.
And I'm going to come up with a
version of this ALOHA protocol
that ends up being a
pretty popular version.
And it's called slotted ALOHA.
And this model that I had from
before where the nodes have
queues, and when two packets
run at the same time they
end up colliding,
all of that remains.
I'm going to add one or two more
restrictions to the kinds of--
to the model.
The first-- an important
thing that defines
slotted ALOHA is
that-- and in fact, it
defines real implementations
of this kind of protocol--
is that time is slotted.
What that means is that
you cannot send a packet
at an arbitrary point in
time onto the network.
Instead, what ends up
happening is that if time--
you view time as a continuous--
as a continuous variable, you
divide up time into time slots.
I mean, these slots
could be any length.
It doesn't matter.
And the assumption
we're going to make
is that packets can only get
transmitted at the beginning
of a time slot.
So these are legal.
Let me-- this is a legal
packet transmission.
And this is a legal
But this is not a legal
packet transmission.
Not allowed.
And the second assumption is
that every packet is an integer
number of time slots.
So in other words,
this is legal.
But this is not legal.
You cannot have a packet
that starts here and ends
in the middle of there.
All packets are an integer
number of time slots.
OK.
So if I have both of
those assumptions,
that tells me ALOHA.
By slotted ALOHA,
we're also going
to make the additional
assumption that each packet is
exactly one time slot long.
Later on, we'll relax
this assumption.
But I want to come up
with the world's simplest
working protocol.
In other words, the only
legal packets in slotted ALOHA
are like that.
OK.
And as shown on
this picture, this
is a picture of how
slotted ALOHA works.
You have time
going on that axis.
Time's divided into slots.
And I have these three different
nodes-- blue, red, and green.
When no node sends
packets in a time slot,
that time slot is
said to be idle
and the channel is said to
be idle in that time slot.
If you have more than one
node sent in a time slot,
we have a collision.
And in our model,
none of the packets
that sent in that time
slot gets decoded.
All of them are wasted.
And everything
else is a success.
If you have a time slot in which
exactly one packet is sent,
we'll assume in this model
that the packet is successfully
decoded and we get to count
that as a successful packet
reception.
So if you count and
look in this picture,
the utilization here is 65%
because we have 20 time slots
here.
And in 13 of those
time slots, we
were able to
successfully transmit
exactly one packet each.
And that gives us the
utilization of 65%.
And the advantage of
picking many of these things
is you can't really
check in real time
if I got the numbers
right or wrong.
You can check that later on.
I'm pretty sure--
I'm not sure of anything.
It's probably correct.
You should just count the number
of slots in which exactly one
guy is sent.
OK.
So that's the picture here.
So what I want to do now is
to come up with an algorithm,
with a protocol, that
each of the nodes
can implement that
allows us to get
reasonable utilization,
reasonable fairness,
and reasonable delay.
And an example of this
protocol, and one way
of solving this
problem, is to solve
the problem in this context
under these assumptions.
And then we're going to
calculate the utilization
of that protocol.
So let me start by telling
you what the protocol is.
The protocol-- each
node independently
runs a version of this protocol.
And in the protocol,
each node maintains--
in the simplest version
of the protocol,
each node maintains
one variable.
And the variable it
maintains is a probability.
So each node
maintains a variable.
I'm going to call it p.
And p is the
probability with which
the node will transmit a packet
if it has a packet to transmit.
In other words, each
node has its own variant,
its own version of p.
And the semantics of this
is that if backlogged,
we won't just greedily
go ahead and transmit.
But instead, if
we're backlogged,
we will transmit our packet on
the channel with probability p.
How do you generate--
how do you actually do
something with probability p?
Like, what would you
do to do something--
if I were asking
you, write a program
to transmit a packet
with probability p,
how will you actually do that?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Call a human
to roll a dice for you.
PROFESSOR: Call a
human to roll a dice.
All right.
Let's try to make it a
little more practical.
Actually, a dice has
only got six sides.
How will I get p out of a dice?
AUDIENCE: A lot of dice.
PROFESSOR: A lot of dice.
OK.
What if I want p with
10 to the minus 17?
AUDIENCE: A lot of [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Yeah,
that's-- all right.
Does someone have a slightly
more practical solution?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Could you have a
random number between 0 and 1
[INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: That sounds good.
So you pick a random
number between 0 and 1.
I mean, how do you get that?
Well, that's a deep question.
But I would just call
random.random in Python,
or whatever the thing is.
And you know, how
Python does it is very--
there's ways to botch it.
But for our purposes,
we'll assume it's correct.
And if the number you get
is less than or equal to p,
that tells you an event
with probability p.
That's great.
OK.
So suppose we did this.
I'm not telling you
how to pick p yet.
That's magic that's going to
come up a little bit later.
But suppose every
node had a value of p,
that someone came and
told it, you know what?
There are n nodes in the system.
Let's assume there are n
backlog nodes in the system.
And I told you that somebody
came and told each node
that it can transmit with p.
What is the utilization
of this protocol?
So if I have n backlog
nodes, each transmitting
with this probability p,
what is the utilization
of the protocol?
I want to know what is
the utilization, which
is, of course, a
function of n and p?
And the way you have
to answer this question
is, of course, you draw
this picture in time
and you divide time into slots.
You've got some of
these things where
you have one packet going
through, some of these things
where more than
one goes through,
in which case, this
is a collision.
And I ask you, what
is the utilization?
How would you calculate it?
Suppose you observe the
running of the protocol
and you find that in some
time slots there's a collision
and in some time
slots there's nothing.
And in some time slots, there's
exactly one transmission.
If you look at
this, how would you
calculate the utilization
of the protocol?
The utilization
is the throughput
over the maximum rate.
What's the maximum
rate of this channel?
Well, the rate is measured in--
the rate here is measured
in packets per time slot.
And I've said that each
packet occupies one time slot.
So the maximum rate
is every time slot
is occupied with a packet.
So the maximum rate is
one packet per time slot.
You cannot send
faster than that.
So the denominator is just one.
Therefore, the
utilization in this model
is simply equal to the
throughput, which is simply
equal to the number
of time slots
in which I have
exactly one packet.
Or put another way, if I
look for a long enough amount
of time, it's the number of
time slots with exactly one
packet that tells
me the throughput,
and therefore, tells
me the utilization.
So if I look for a
very, very long time
and I count the number
of successful packets,
that's going to tell
me the utilization
if I take the number and divide
by the number of time slots.
And therefore,
the utilization is
equal to simply the
fraction of time slots
in which I have one packet
and exactly one packet sent,
which is equivalent to
asking, what's the probability
that in any given
time slot, I have
exactly one successful--
one exactly one packet sent?
So I'm going to repeat this.
The utilization of this
protocol is exactly
equal to the probability
that in any given time slot,
I have exactly one transmission.
If you disagree
with that statement,
you have to raise your hand now,
or if you don't understand it,
so I can explain it
again, because we're
going to use this idea
repeatedly in pretty much--
there's guaranteed to be some
question on the quiz related
to this idea.
And then you have to work
some probability out.
So does everyone understand why
the utilization of the protocol
is equal to the probability
that in any time slot
there's exactly one
transmission of a packet?
The reason why that's true is
it follows from this definition
because the maximum rate here
is one packet per time slot.
And so I want to know
what the throughput is.
The throughput is simply, I
look over a long period of time,
many time slots,
and I count what's
the number of packets I sent.
So if I take the number
of successful packets
I sent and divide by the
number of time slots,
well, that's actually the
definition of a probability
that in any given time
slot I have exactly one
successful transmission.
And therefore, the utilization
is equal to the probability
that I have exactly
one transmission.
So I have n backlog nodes.
Each guy sends with
probability p in a time slot.
What's the probability that I
have exactly one transmission?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Well,
there's certainly
a p, which is success,
times 1 minus p
to the n minus 1, which is
all the other guys keep quiet.
Is this right?
It's almost right.
AUDIENCE: And then
times n because there's
n ways to [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Times n.
There's an n choose
one, which is
there are n ways
to pick the winner,
and therefore that's the answer.
All right.
Let's hold n times-- so
let me write this as u
equals n times p times 1
minus p to the n minus 1.
Suppose you knew n.
Suppose n were some value--
10, 15, whatever.
Therefore, I would view
this-- assuming n is constant,
I could view this
as a function of p.
If I want to maximize
this utilization,
I want to-- obviously I
want to maximize it, right?
If I want to maximize
the utilization,
what should be p be?
Or I'll call it p star.
What's the value of p
equal to p star that
maximizes this utilization?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: 1 over n.
PROFESSOR: 1 over n.
Yeah, you could do this the
hard way or the easy way.
AUDIENCE: Differentiating
[INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: Great.
So if you did that, the answer
works out to be p star--
if you do u prime of p equals
0 and you solve that, you'll
find that p star is 1 over n.
The long way to do it
is the way you describe.
But the answer is intuitive
because what it really
says is that, if I did
have every node transmit
with probability 1
over n in a time slot,
the expected number of
transmissions within any given
time slot is n times 1 over
n, which is 1, which is
kind of what you would expect.
You would expect
that to maximize
the utilization, the expected
number of nodes that transmit
at any given time slot is 1.
And that's fortunately
what you do
get if you solve the equation.
So p star is 1 over n.
So if somebody told you the
number of backlogged nodes
in the network and
they had the ability
to program each node to set
the appropriate probability,
the probability you
would use is 1 over n.
So let's assume still
this world where we know
the number of backlog nodes.
And somebody came and told us
the probability we should use.
Do I need anything here?
Let me erase this.
If somebody came and told you
the probability you should use,
you would pick 1 over n.
That's great.
So now therefore I
can now view u star
of n, which is the maximum
probability now becomes
a function of n, because I can
go back in here and I can set--
assuming you picked
this value of p,
you can stick p equal to
1 over n in this formula
and then you get a utilization
that's purely a function of n
because I want to draw
this picture of what
it looks like with n.
So you start off n
is equal to n times 1
over n, which is the value of
p that's the best value of p,
times 1 minus 1 over
n to the n minus 1.
Does that makes sense?
Haven't done anything
other than substitute
a value of p star
equal to 1 over n.
And that's equal to 1 minus 1
over n to the power n minus 1.
Now, one of the
questions we want to ask
is, is this how--
this is the best you
can do in this protocol.
How good or how bad is it?
So let's draw a picture
of what this looks like
as n becomes large.
So I want to draw a picture
of n on this axis and the best
value of the utilization, which
is u star of n on this axis.
Well, when n is 1, get to n is
1-- actually, intuitively, when
n is 1, what's the utilization?
When you have one backlog
node and the protocol
runs with the value of
p equal to 1 over n,
what's the utilization?
The utilization is 1.
This formula, you got to
take the limit, and so on.
But the answer is 1.
So let's assume this is 1
and 2 and 3 and 4, and so on.
So it's 1.
What is it when n equals 2?
What's the utilization
when n equals 2?
Well, it's 1/2 to the
power 1, which is 50%.
So I get a value which is 1/2.
When n is 3, what happens?
Well, 1 minus 1/3 squared,
which is 4 over 9.
As n goes bigger and
bigger and bigger,
what does this value become?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yeah, as n goes
bigger and bigger and bigger,
you do the limit when n goes to
infinity of this thing here. n
minus 1 and n are more
or less the same thing,
so you can get rid of that.
This should be a
well-known limit.
If you don't know
it, you take the log.
You take the log and
you find the limit
as it goes to infinity.
You can expand that
into a power series.
And you'll find
that the answer--
the limit of the log is
minus 1 or this value,
the limit goes to 1 over e.
So in fact, it goes to a
value which is 1 over e when
n is large, or about 37%.
This is actually not bad.
It's actually very good.
For a protocol that did nothing
sophisticated, all it did
was pick a value of
this probability.
The fact that it's able to
get not a zero utilization
but a reasonably
good utilization
is an extremely strong--
is a pretty strong result.
And that's the basic
ALOHA protocol.
The basic ALOHA protocol,
or a fixed probability ALOHA
protocol, is
somebody telling you
the number of backlogged nodes
and you using that information
to make sure that every node
sends with some probability.
And they just-- and
the probability you
would pick is 1 over n.
Now, this is not actually
a very practical protocol,
because how do you know which
nodes have backlogged packets
and which nodes don't?
What we would like us to come
up with a way by which we
automatically have a
protocol that somehow
gets us to the
correct utilization.
And we're going to do that by
adding a method to this ALOHA
protocol that will make
it completely practical.
And that method is
called stabilization.
And the purpose of
stabilization is
to determine at each node
what the actual value of p
it should use is.
And that value of p is
going to change with time
as other nodes have traffic
to send and if nodes go away.
So the magic protocol
is going to be somehow
that we're able to change
the value of p at every node.
Every node runs an
algorithm which adapts
its value of p over time.
And if there's a lot of
competition, the value of p
will reduce.
If there's very little
competition, the value of p
increases.
And if we do that,
we're going to be
able to get pretty
good utilization.
And this process is
called stabilization.
AUDIENCE: Are we still
assuming that all of the nodes
are transmitting with
the same probability?
PROFESSOR: Nope.
The nodes will end
up not transmitting
with the same probability
because they're each
going to be making
independent decisions.
So the first thing
we're going to do
is each node is still
going to have a p.
But in fact, node i is going
to have its own variable.
So we're going to say that
node i has its own variable
that only it knows.
And its probability is p i.
So the way we're going
to do the stabilization
is very, very simple.
We're going to say that at
node i, it's going to do--
well, the only information
it gets is it sends a packet.
And if the packet succeeds,
it knows something.
If the packet doesn't
succeed, it knows something.
So let's say that a node sends
a packet and the packet fails.
And the way you know that
a packet fails-- and I
haven't talked about this.
But the way this protocol--
all these protocols-- end up
working is they send
a packet and then
they watch to see if the
packet succeeds or not.
They can get that information
by an acknowledgment
coming from the receiver.
Or in the case of
certain networks,
like ethernet, when
you send a packet,
if you aren't able to receive
your own packet on that bus,
then you know that it's failed.
So that's just a detail.
But the assumption
here is there's
some feedback that tells
the node whether a packet
transmission succeeded or not.
In general, it's with
an acknowledgment
that comes from the receiver.
If you get an ACK,
it means it succeeds.
So we're going to
have two rules.
If you don't succeed-- in other
words, there's a collision--
then you do something.
And in contrast, if you
succeed, you do something.
So what we're going to
do on a collision is,
let's say that you send a
packet and it didn't succeed.
It collided.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: So with
the acknowledgement,
what if the
acknowledgement fails?
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
You're out of luck,
because in reality,
in Wi-Fi, when an
acknowledgment fails,
what ends up happening is you
assume the packet collided.
So how people deal with this
problem is typically to--
essentially to do very
strong error protection
on the acknowledgment.
You send it at a
very low bitrate.
And what that really
means is you're
adding a lot of redundancy
to that acknowledgment.
So imagine you're
coding the heck out
of it using channel coding.
That's what happens.
OK.
Let's say you send a
packet and it collides.
What should you do to the
node's transmission probability?
Increase it or reduce it?
AUDIENCE: Reduce it.
PROFESSOR: Sorry?
PROFESSOR: Reduce it,
because the assumption is it
collided because presumably
there's a lot of competition
and you're a nice guy.
And your assumption is
that all the other nodes
are nice people, too, which
is kind of changing nowadays
with all these
software defined radios
and the hacking that you
can do on Wi-Fi cards.
It's possible for your node
to not actually back off.
But if you're a nice node,
what you're going to do
is you're going to
reduce the probability.
And one way of doing that,
a good way of doing that,
is called multiplicative
reduction,
or multiplicative decrease.
You reduce it by a factor of 2.
You just halve it.
And on a success, you could do
a bunch of different things.
But one thing you can do is
you can be a little bit greedy
and say, all right.
I succeeded, which means there's
not that much competition
in the network.
Maybe there's nobody else in
the network, in which case, I
want to keep trying to increase
my transmission probability.
And maybe you double it.
And my notes talk about
whether this is right
or something else is right.
But it really doesn't matter.
It turns out the important
rule is this rule.
The protocol turns
out to be not very
sensitive to how you increase.
You do have to increase.
But it doesn't
matter how you do it.
Now, of course, the
probabilities can't exceed 1.
So we're going to actually pick
the minimum of 2 times p and 1.
This is our basic
stabilization protocol.
Now, every node has
its own version of p.
And so you may run
with a p of 0.8
and I might be at a p of 0.1.
Presumably, if I succeed,
I'm going to increase.
If you fail, you're
going to decrease.
And something happens.
The question is, what happens?
And that's what I
want to show you.
I'm going to skip all the
stuff we went through.
So if I run this protocol
exactly as I've described
on this board here-- and
this is an experiment with--
you'll be doing all this
stuff in the lab yourself.
This is with 10 nodes.
What you see is that you have
a utilization of 0.33, which
is not too far from the 1
over e utilization, which
is remarkable that this protocol
where everybody just jumped
around multiplicatively
changing p i like this
worked out to be a
pretty good utilization.
But there's a big
problem in the protocol.
And the problem in the
protocol is that the fairness
is pretty terrible.
As it happens, it's 0.47.
I was reminded that
47% of the nodes
here got pretty
healthy throughput.
It's probably looking for
handouts or something.
But anyway, it's pretty bad.
And what's going on
here is that when
a node is running at a high
value of its probability
and some other node is at a
low value of the probability,
if they collide, the
guy with the higher
value of its probability
reduces some by a factor of 2,
but it's still a
pretty high value,
whereas if a node has a
probability of transmission,
somehow it's got screwed and
it's now running at 1 over 32,
it becomes 1 over
64, then 1 over 128.
It's practically 0.
It doesn't ever get out of
that real morass that it's in
and ever start being able to
successfully transmit again.
And that's what's
happening here.
And the way you
solve this problem--
there's a very simple
solution to this problem.
The way you solve
this problem is you
decide that nobody should get
really, really poor, that you
decide that you're going to have
a value of the probability p
min that will never
actually get--
you'll never go below that.
So you modify the
protocol to do that.
And if you do that, you end up
with much better performance.
You end up with performance
that looks like this.
And you'll see this in the lab.
But what you find here is
something very puzzling.
What you find here is that
the fairness is amazing.
It's 99.99, which is really,
really good fairness.
But what you find is that
the utilization is 0.71.
That's actually too
good to be true,
because the best
utilization you could expect
is probably around 37%.
And the fact is, we're getting
something astonishingly good.
What's happening here
actually is something
that's really important.
It took people a few
years to figure it out.
It's called the capture effect.
What's happening here is
that some node captures
the channel for quite a
substantial period of time,
shutting everybody else out.
And then some
other node captures
the channel for
some period of time,
shutting everybody else out.
So you get significant
short term unfairness.
Or equivalently, you
get a long delay.
So some nodes may end up
waiting for a long time.
And then they get access.
And then they keep
access for quite a while.
And then they lose access.
And then some
other nodes get it.
So what's really
going on here is,
even though you have many, many
nodes competing, at any point
in time, effectively
the competition is only
between one or two nodes.
And this is a problem
called the capture effect.
And the way you
solve this problem
is symmetrically to change
this value of the probability,
there's a maximum
value, which is p max.
So you have to pick a different
value that's less than 1
that's the maximum probability.
In other words, once a node
has a transmission probability
of, let's say, 0.25
or 0.3, you don't
want to have it keep increasing,
because what ends up happening
is then it captures the
channel for quite a while.
And it's only upon
successive collisions
that it comes down to the
point where other nodes can
gain access to the channel.
So if you put all
of that together
and run the
experiment, we're just
putting this protocol
as described exactly
on this board.
And you can play
around with this thing.
There's a lot of leeway in
picking these parameters.
If you run this protocol,
you get a utilization,
in this case, of 0.41,
which for n equal to 10
is pretty much what
you would get according
to sticking into that formula a
fairness that's extremely high.
And it's super cool because
this is exactly what you
would want to get.
If somebody magically told you
the number of backlogged nodes
and you theoretically
calculated the optimal value
of the probability, you couldn't
do better than this protocol.
And we managed to do it
by simply these nodes that
are just independently
making these decisions,
figuring out what
they should do.
And if you were to plot
the actual evolution
of the probabilities, you
find that at no point in time
does any node have
a value of 1 over n.
Even though in the
experiment there's
some value of the number
of backlogged nodes,
the nodes kind of
dance around it.
But they never
actually stick to it.
But they conspire
to dance around it
in a way that gives you
exactly the same result as you
would get if you, in fact,
had a pretty good thing.
I'm going to close
with one last comment.
This is from s
student from about,
I think, two terms ago, a
guy called Chase Lambert,
who took this class.
And I was very
gratified to hear this,
because it turned
out he interned
or he is working or
worked or working
at a company called Quizlet,
which is a startup company.
And one of the things he had
to do was a load generator.
And he ended up using exactly
these ideas to come up
with a load generating
scheme that was stable,
because you want to
be able to generate
load that allows you to measure
the throughput of a system.
And he used this
random back off idea.
So it's not that you'll
find these ideas useful
only if you were doing
this kind of networking.
You actually find these ideas
useful in other contexts.
So I'm going to stop here.
We'll pick up on some of
these topics in recitation,
and then back here on Monday.